Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
So I want to continue this
series on studying effectively.
And whereas in the previous video I
talked about studying effectively in
general, and I'm referring of course to
studying mostly in a school environment
or a university environment, and in
the first video I talked about studying
effectively in general, in this video, I
want to talk about studying effectively
when it comes to learning languages.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell to get notifications.
Why is it that so many people
struggle to learn languages at school?
Now I'm referring to the situation,
for example, in Canada, within the
English school system, where very
few, uh, outside of French immersion,
which is where English speaking
kids do all of their schooling in
French, which is a great program.
And perhaps a few hundred, I don't know,
four or 500,000 kids every year do that.
But in the regular French stream,
very few kids end up speaking French.
I mean, that's just the reality.
Uh, I don't know what the situation is in
the US with regard to foreign languages,
Spanish or in the UK for that matter.
I know that in countries like
Sweden, and in Europe, in many
countries in Europe, kids do learn.
I'm not sure if they learn in school
or whether they learn because in
the case of Sweden, they have, um,
you know, uh, the, uh, television
programs, English or American
television programs are not dubbed.
So they're provided in
the, uh, original version.
So the kids actually, before
they even start school,
they've heard a lot of English.
And so they speak English.
Well, But if I look at the situation
in Canada, uh, I think there are
a number of reasons why language
instruction in school is not effective.
And it kind of goes against some of
the principles of effective study.
So first of all, the emphasis in schools,
despite what people say is on tests.
And it's on testing people
for specifics of grammar.
So, um, I mentioned in that previous video
that in the UK for their, uh, geez, can't
remember the GSE or whatever general,
you know, national tests that they have.
They were testing people on specific
points of grammar, and this would then
determine whether the learner got their
diploma or didn't get their diploma.
Issues of grammar that
are actually quite minor.
They're there, yes.
For example, in French you say
"joue au football", "joue au..."
whatever, you know, a sport,
for example, "joue du piano".
But if you got that wrong, it
would not inhibit communication.
If a person understands French well
and is able to communicate well and
makes the odd mistake like that, it's
not that serious because the majority
of students in the school system end
up not being able to speak at all,
not being able to understand at all.
So what's the possible point of testing
them on these specific points of grammar?
All it does is introduce an element
of frustration, um, sense of failure.
Uh, plus it's unfair because, okay,
as I pointed out in the earlier video,
our brains are not so good at grabbing
these details, but are our brains will
gradually develop a series of patterns
around how this foreign language works.
And so given enough exposure
to the language, the learners
will gradually get better.
And if the goal is to be able to use
the language in a practical way to
understand, to communicate meaning
then really testing people on specific
points of grammar that are taught in
grade four, grade six or grade eight,
and therefore right away, we will test
you on whether you learned it or not.
It's actually pointless.
It's just building in more
resistance to the language.
And again, referring to my earlier
video, we want learners to explore the
language, to cover the same ground.
Using different materials, different
stories, different content.
And of course the specific
grammatical points will show up.
And these other, you know, uh, contexts.
And the brain will gradually
start to pick up on them.
And it's possible that, uh, once the
brain has had enough experience with sort
of these aspects of the language, and if
the teacher points out that we say "joue
au", and in the case of a sport and "joue
du" in the case of a musical instrument
that that might help the learner remember
that, and then they might still get
it wrong and it doesn't really matter.
So, uh, I think the, the, the problem
in, in language instruction in schools
is the teacher decides what the
learner is going to use as a textbook.
I've even heard teachers discourage
learners from going beyond
what the teacher is teaching.
The teacher wants to control
what the learner is learning.
The content that learner is using.
Uh, again, on this, uh, exchange I saw
on Twitter, there's some discussion in
the UK as to which high frequency words
learners should have to demonstrate that
they know in order to get their diploma.
Well, the words that the learner knows
is going to reflect what they have read.
It's going to reflect what
they're interested in.
The fact that they don't know the
word "now", if they got into a
situation where this word appeared
frequently, they'd learn it.
So again, I think that's an unnecessary,
specific detail to test people on
rather, how do you encourage people?
And this is difficult in the
case of French in Canada.
If you live in Vancouver, There's not an
awful lot of opportunity to use French,
but the emphasis, the focus should be on
how do you get students to graze in the
language, to explore in the language?
Maybe even if you want them to learn
French, let them choose the language
they want to learn, because if they
learn Spanish and they've got some
confidence that they can learn the
language, assuming they're more motivated
to learn Spanish or Chinese or whatever
it might be, if they achieve that,
then it'll be easier for
them to learn French.
In other words, effective study is based
on the idea that the student is motivated.
And I know that's difficult.
You've got a classroom of 25 kids that
aren't very motivated, but the challenge
has to be how do we motivate these kids?
If what we do in other words, insisting
on certain grammatical niceties of
the language or a certain set of
words that have to be learned, and
this will be the proof of whether
the student has achieved that level.
If we are building in frustration
and disappointment and, uh, you
know, resistance to the language,
um, we're not helping the situation.
And the proof is in the pudding
because at least in the case of
Canada, the vast majority of students
in the English language stream
graduate after eight or 10 years of
French, and can't speak French, don't
understand French, can't speak French.
I mean, they speak some, they might
understand some, but essentially
they're not functional in French.
So I think that's why we have to
recognize that, that the brain doesn't
respond to this kind of, uh, you
know, you must learn this now and then
you get the student to sit down and
try and block learn this thing now.
That's not how it works.
Effective study involves
the sort of grazing.
And also again, in, in school
instruction, the emphasis is, is
A on grammar and B on speaking.
They have this sort of role playing
and getting the students to speak.
They have nothing to say until they
understand well and have a sufficient sort
of level of experience with the language.
They can't say that much.
If they enjoy doing it, fine, but,
but that should not be in my view, the
main, uh, sort of form of instruction,
emphasis on being able to say a few
things, because once you have...
So you have an artificial situation in
the classroom where the student pretends
that they're a whatever, uh, you know,
a store clerk or buying something.
And once they're back in the real world,
none of that's gonna work for them.
So it's far better to focus again,
as I said earlier, with sort of
studying effectively, generally
improve the reading skill.
And how do you improve reading skills?
By reading a lot.
So get them to read, let them
choose what they want to read.
It doesn't matter what they read.
If they're reading a lot, they're going
to be improving their reading skills.
And get them to listen and listen
to material that they like.
And to voices that they like.
So, you know, they, the same idea that the
most efficient way to bring information
into the brain, to stimulate the brain, to
get the brain to form these new patterns
is through a lot of listening and reading.
Of course, when opportunities are
there to speak, we should speak,
but we shouldn't make that the
sort of main short term goal.
It will eventually be the long-term goal.
And yeah, once the brain has enough
experience with the language, has
developed these patterns to cope
with that language, then of course
we want to speak as much as possible,
but again, It should be meaningful.
So meaningful conversation
talking about meaningful things.
And if we will, you know, once we
have sufficient, a sufficient base
in the language, we can help the
student find people if not in the
classroom, even online that they can
talk to and talk in a meaningful way,
not in a circle role-playing way.
So there you go.
My view on why language instruction
in the schools is not effective, at
least in English-speaking Canada.
And I have the impression from this
exchange I saw on Twitter there are
serious problems in the UK as well.
And if we look at the results in
terms of how many people speak a
foreign language in those countries,
uh, hasn't been very effective.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.